royals lefty chris bubich making his
ninth start of the year
he's already learned what major league
hitters do when that changeup's floating
in the middle
mix in the curve the curve is huge all
three pitches
all the same the value's the same fizz
he can do it he's got confidence now
i'm expecting a good outing from him
robbie grossman will lead things off for
detroit
to the right side with merrifield
run out and here is our eric haas who is
a backup for much of his career before
this year but he has been absolutely
sensational well he has induced
10 double plays this year that's a good
number keep it down
he gets him to chase and bobich gets his
first strikeout of the night took
advantage
of an over anxious eric haas
now the royal killer through the years
miguel cabrera stay down
0-2 same situation make him
came right after him with the fastball
down the heart of the plate
and struck him out terrific first inning
for chris
willie peralta will be towing the rubber
tonight making his seventh start for the
tigers he's notched his third win of the
season
his last start on sunday versus
minnesota
tossed seven scoreless innings and over
his last five starts peralta has allowed
just one
earned run merrifield santana perez to
face him here in the first inning mayor
field
to right field no problem for victor
reyes
here's the two otis antenna to center
field
derek hill is there and puts it away
into the shift and on the backhand
willie castro bobbled it for a moment
but a strong arm enough
to get salvador perez and retire the
royals
one two three
on the ground nice diving save made by
zack short and he throws out ben and
tendy for the first out here in the
second
we talk about the great defense helping
these pitchers out there's another
great example zach short on the shift
goes hard to his left
but he has to get up and get rid of it
quickly and he does that also
so good play all around for short
the o2 to o'hare swung
right there perfect example of it and
ten pitches
willie peralta did there in the second
no score top of the third inning and
willie castro a switch hitter will dig
in against chris bubich
willy castro on the first pitch he sees
drills it to left it's gone willy castro
with a solo homer
to lead off the third and the tigers
have the early lead wow catches just by
surprise sometimes chef but that's uh
that's a good start for
detroit what great extension that was
hitting right handed
he drilled that ball into the left field
bleachers
that ball hit sharply dozier has it
second one first
base two that's a double play tremendous
start to the play by dozier
stabbing it with a backhand man that was
beautiful
the crowd here at the cave loved it
they'll be able to win to come through
with a clutch two out hit
or will he knows of whit merrifield's
success
against the tigers he has been
outstanding
airfield tied with santana for second
most rbis in the team
51. and he smacks that one to left field
here comes hunter dozier here comes the
throw
not in time royals have tied it
[Applause]
to third dozier second one first base
two that's a double play and pubic gets
out of a
troubling jam in the fourth two on one
out to ryan o'hearns
royals won tigers one bottom of the
fourth
ben attendees at second solaire's at
first
smacks that one well deep to center
field that's the way
back and that is out of here
oh what a ball that was opposite field
here at the k
ah way to give your team a lift and you
keep swinging like that
you will have a hard time coming out of
the lineup great easy swing
look at the finish that finish on that
swing was
picturesque
lopez goes to second though he's going
to go to first and he gets grossman are
you kidding me
oh man that's funny i thought his only
chance was its second and nicki goes the
long way
that's phenomenal how you're running
full
speed and you can find a grip enough to
get it over there
santana helped him with the pick and
he's out what a play go ahead nikki
lopez
show your skills now carlos santana
applied to center field in the first
rounded out to first
in the third pay it well
into the corner
and gone
carlos santana with his 16th home run
and that puts an end to the split finger
as far as nobody getting a hit off of it
there it was see it stayed up now those
that stay up
he didn't even get a good swing on it
but they really jumped skull for third
cabrera second candelario first pitch 25
of the inning coming
short ground ball to lopez second one
first base
yes oh
man bubba just got the double play magic
working
third double play tonight are you
kidding me look at the good hands people
were
first man sure second man quick three
yes now it's full grossman is a tough
out
because he'll hit it wherever it spits
they're playing him to pull oh
nice he struck him out beauty look at
that had him way off balance
that's like a slider
another o2 in the dirt steps away from
perez
castro will score hill moves up to third
it's now 5-2 level 1-2
to right field and that's going to drop
in front of jarrod dyson
jonathan scope comes through on a
one-two pitch his
second hit of the night it's an rbi
single to bring the tigers to within two
he struck him out and the royals
take game one mike matheny's blue
ends the detroit tigers win streak at
seven games